what is your what would be your Turing
test what will be the test that if a
machine passes that we'd say now the
machine has equal rights to a human okay
so does everyone know what the Turing
test is right so Alan Turing even even
before we hit started to build AI
thought about what it would be to say
that the machine could think and propose
this idea of a Turing test though when
you couldn't tell a machine apart from a
human then you might as well say that
the machine thinks I mean but the first
thing to say is that people working in
AI don't think about passing the Turing
test I mean it's more what Germany will
call a good danken experiment Red's a
thought experiment well what would it
mean as opposed to there is this thing
every year there's little opener prize
is a cheering like test that's applied
but but most people in AI aren't working
towards solving the Loebner prize or
thinking that that's you know most of us
awake in just some small part of AI that
will one day be integrated into the
whole and increasingly you're not going
to notice I mean Andrew Ming who used to
be the chief scientist at Baidu says
that AI is going to be like electricity
it's going to be everywhere it's going
to pass everywhere you go
electricity powers everything it powers
the light in this room it's powering the
TV camera powering this microphone is
giving all the data on your computer so
not only is it providing power it's also
the carrier for the data it's integral
to our lives today and AI is going to be
like that everywhere you go a is going
to be there it's going to be part of
your life every room you walk into
you'll say room what's on my schedule
today and even though this is a room
that you haven't been in before the room
will recognize your voice a
biometrically authenticate you to check
your schedule and then will tell you and
then you say who won the football and
the room will know which football team
you follow to say you know which match
it was and who we were which team in
that match won AI is going to follow you
round your life and you won't even know
it will be such an integral part of your
life ai will eventually be of course the
operating system of your computer
right there's already you can already
see the beginnings of that AI now is
becoming you know you're having more of
a conversation with computers as you
know the history of operating systems is
it went from you know be literally
plugging wires into computers to writing
bits of machine code to to Windows and
typing things and windows the next level
is going to be you have a conversation
you say to the computer you know find
out you know when my wife is going to be
home tonight
yeah so eventually you're not going to
notice it's AI we can in fact I think
we're going to run into a problem which
is that is that we'll be interacting
with things that we won't know whether
they're people like your computers my
question was a bit different I think
maybe I didn't I probably didn't water
correctly it's more about when there's
an AI when it when does it become
unethical to turn off an AI okay well
that is there's the opposite that is
another dimension of this question I
mean well we have no idea we have no I
mean we certainly don't build machines
that have any sort of sentence or
consciousness any sort of feelings or
emotions maybe the machines will clearly
have to understand emotions right if
they could have going to spend more and
more of our lives interacting with
machines they'll need to understand our
emotions so they're going to have to be
able to have a better emotional
intelligence they have today maybe we'll
even give them emotions maybe there'll
be those will be fake emotions we don't
know we don't know we don't really
understand enough about our real
emotions what our real emotions like
well I mean we do understand a little
bit about emotions they're you know
they're chemical but right I said
different from code that gets executed
right but so maybe we have to give you
know a chemical aspect of machines so
they have things like emotions emotions
are clearly really important they're a
big part of our lives right we wake up
we are emotional they're there they
evolutions equipped us with emotions and
they seem to serve some useful purpose
they help us make decisions quickly and
so on so maybe we'll end up giving
machines emotions or maybe we'll end up
giving machines fake emotions we don't
know whether
be real emotions we don't know whether
we're to be conscious I mean we your
question comes down also to the side
here of consciousness we don't have no
idea it's about one of the most unsolved
questions in size say what is
consciousness and you know the
interesting thing is will it be an
emergent phenomenon when we build
sufficiently complex AIS we don't know
maybe well maybe maybe they will be as
David Chalmers the philosopher said
there'll be just zombie intelligence it
will be intelligence like Spock it will
be incredibly smart but have no
emotional content to it there's no
necessity it seems we have no reason to
suppose necessity that the AIS we build
will have any consciousness or any
emotions they may be just really good
decision makers without any of that
emotions and consciousness but
consciousness seems to be a really
important part of our lives and maybe
you know they're too integral to being
able to gaze ethically you have to be
conscious you know we wake up from the
moment you're awake to the moment you
fall asleep it's the thing that defines
your existence and your intelligence as
you lose your consciousness so maybe we
will end up building consciousness into
machines or maybe they will become
coaches we don't know I mean that's one
of the reef in teresting things of
studying AIS but maybe it will help us
answer this question and tell us
something about ourselves but maybe
people forget when we talk about AI the
AI means artificial intelligence and
people focus on the intelligence as
opposed to the artificial and it's
actually for better or worse it seems
quite a good name because it may be that
we build intelligence that's very
artificial very different to our natural
intelligence that looks very different
it doesn't have consciousness doesn't
have emotions it's very different type
of intelligence it's very interesting
way of interpreting artificial I've
never thought about it that way and so
you know that's why is so interesting I
mean the next few years can help answer
these fundamental questions which is
much about us about our consciousness or
emotional lives and it is about our
machines and the you know there's a good
side effects we'll have these smart
machines that could do all these things
we're still all working so you know it's
a great question that asks leads into
lots of issues
okay and AI is creating content for the
social media it's creating ads and so on
it's choosing for us and the best social
media content so it's optimized for
usage time I would say in Facebook
YouTube and so on it's creating ads and
optimizing and them for clicks and
conversions how do you think that the
Society's opinion is changed by these
optimizations I think we really have to
start worrying about this if we we used
to think that the internet was going to
be this open environment that
facilitated discussion and and so on but
now we're starting to worry that we're
living in these echo chambers where it
reinforces the things that we want to
hear allows very extreme views to gain
currency and who is responsible it's it
seems to me it's it's absurd that we
discover Facebook's rules for censoring
because of the Guardians investigative
reporting they are today the biggest
news provider on the planet and yet we
had no say there's no society say about
the rules that govern the freedom of
speech on Facebook it was only by chance
by then investigating and leaking the
private rules that they use that we
discover what norms are being applied
and whether there are norms or not I
mean we have as a society agreed on
various things about about promoting
racism about the analysis 'im about
about you know inciting hatred and
things like this we have first norms and
they're different norms and different
societies and yet Facebook is applying
each their own rules which may not like
align with those norms and quite
honestly I think we've been giving
Silicon Valley too much of a free ride
that they have responsibilities and they
need to be responsible and and our
governments are not regulating them
enough
it was you know when when some of the
fake news controversy started at the end
of last year Facebook's immediate
response was when we're just an
intermediary and we're not responsible
later on in January Mark Zuckerberg
wrote his letter where he put his hand
up and said okay would take some
responsibility for this but that was
only ask there was an initial reaction
and it you know it disappoints me that
we're only getting to this beginning of
this conversations and interestingly
enough though in his letter he talks
about well how are we going to tackle
this some of it is by human human senses
but that's challenging because these
people get exposed to material which
actually you know may even hurt them
damage they end up with you know trauma
firm from having seen some of all this
material but also just to do it just to
do it on the scale planet wide scale
that Facebook works and the only way
they can do it and this is what the
letter says is by using AI so not only
we part of the problem but we also part
of the cure again which is the only way
you can hope to to be able to try and
filter information at the speed that is
coming in to Facebook and YouTube and
please places like this is if you use AI
to do the filtering for you and so we're
also part of the cure is but as well as
part of the problem but I think these
are really important questions about you
know about society about about our
values and about how technology
companies have a responsibility and we
we are not actually I think holding
technology count companies enough to
account it's not just Tesla I mean I was
rude about Tesla in the talk but I think
you know I could be rude about Facebook
I could be rude about Google and you
know they they are having a huge impact
upon our lives and they're unanswerable
there these are corporations that are as
wealthy as small countries these days
then and they're not behaving
responsibly they're not paying taxes
they're not supporting the countries in
which their wealth is being generated
and it is not at all clear to me that
their values align with societies
they're trying to maximize shareholder
profit that is not necessarily the same
as
agreeing with the norms that we as a
society want to make our societies will
open more prosperous more healthy more
free and it doesn't seem that those
necessarily line up thank you hello
thank you for the great talk actually I
have a question about autonomous driving
and accountability so you were talking
about the first death in an autonomous
driving car
what is the first death so there's
possibly a death in China that happened
just before oh but they don't know it
was so violent an accident the black box
on the car is doesn't actually whether
it was an autopilot or not so a Chinese
person drone looks like it probably was
because it drove into the back of a
street cleaning truck what was on the
side of the road killed the Chinese the
Chinese youth who had borrowed the car
from his father all right but I think
and the quest much question still is and
who's actually accountable in that case
so it seemed in your talk that the
driver was actually accounted for
because the driver made a mistake he
wasn't he was watching I think Harry
Potter movies or something on it I think
I think everybody yes maybe but if you
go to like in the pharmaceutical area
usually people have to test drugs if
they have any kind of lethal side effect
everybody has a very clearly defined
responsibility on what he has to do and
I think in your honest opinion who do
you think is accountable in this case it
is a Tesla is it the car or is it the
driver but Tesla's lawyers will say the
driver was responsible of course they
would say that when he started the car
in the morning he Presley you know okay
button on which gave you no approval for
the autopilot to take over and he would
keep his hands on the wheel and but
everyone knows that you can't expect
people to pay attention for long periods
of time unless they have to do something
this is the this is a long going debate
in the in the airline industry about
increasingly the cockpit is automated
and and pilots who are
trained individuals who are paid to be
there
find struggle to maintain awareness of
what the plane is doing given that most
of the time the computers flying the
plane and they're really struggling with
this issue which is that how can you
take back control at short notice if you
haven't been you know driving the car
previously on the car it wasn't a matter
we did have systems like in a cruise
control where the computer is in charge
but you still had to drive so you had to
still pay most of the attention so you
were still focused on the driving once
you stopped having to focus on the
driving then there's a real argument
which is the you can't expect humans to
take back control short notice there are
these different levels of automation go
from level zero in automation up to full
automation level five and we're at level
three moving into level four and there's
an argument have level 3 or level four
you have to go straight to five you
can't expect humans to be able to take
back control Tesla is being
irresponsible to expect human drivers to
pay attention when they've got nothing
to do for half an hour and that's there
I think this there's quite a lot of
validity to that argument there's also a
validity argument which is that is that
okay maybe they can argue that the human
driver has responsibility because they
signed the release they click the button
but when they when they kill as they
will do invariably a pedestrian or a
cyclist those pedestrian cyclist won't
have any agreement with Tesla and it and
for example cyclists for the most
vulnerable people today in autonomous
cars and you talk to people who builds
autonomous cars may say it's really
difficult to work out they've got unless
they really difficult to work out which
way a bicycle is going even now because
bicycle bike reversals go the wrong way
down the streets surprisingly enough so
just because they're on a street one way
street doesn't mean they're going the
right way down a one-way street so
bicyclists are very unpredictable
they also very hard to see because
they're small objects there's no radar
signal and so invariably they're going
to kill a cyclist before too long they
can a turn left you know as drivers do
and they will kill a cyclist who didn't
you know as know
agreement with Tesla so I think you know
these companies are behaving
irresponsibly another reason in the
airline industry well when a life
started flying was really dangerous
hundred years ago when airlines were
priam plane fell out of the sky was very
dangerous but we made it the safest form
of travel we instigated various
mechanisms to make sure it is now the
safest form of travel if there's an
accident
it gets investigated the ntsc or whoever
comes in investigates it and finds the
cause so the systems can be changed the
the hardware can be fixed or the
procedures the pylons follow can be
changed so the accident never gets
repeated and then that information is
shared with the whole industry not with
this one company not with Boeing but
with everyone everyone gets to learn
from the improvements
whereas what you see today with with
with autonomous cars it's a race no one
wants to share any information with
anyone else right and they're not being
forced to share the information so so
that what Tesla learns is not shared
with four-door Toyota or or uber or
anyone else again I think you know
governments are being irresponsible
because there's a you know there's a
trillion dollar industry car industry
and there's a race to be the winners of
that as that industry it's not necessary
the car come is the future are not
necessarily Ford General Motors and
Toyota it might be Apple Google and uber
and so there's a race to win this
industry and government is reluctant to
regulate where we should be regulating
so that it will be the safest form of
travel
thank you for your token and decision
and one of your concerns during the duck
was this bias racial bias in fryers and
bias and I don't fully agree with the
idea this idea of we will inherit the
bias from society when we build machine
learning systems it should be fairly
simple or easy to
to remove this bias if we agree
beforehand on the the bias that we
should and have in our society for
example male or female we could easily
remove that from a machine learning
algorithm so my my question is if you
could elaborate a bit more on that and
how what is it what is the real danger
of of using historical data if we can
easily remove that my point is we could
I believe that we could use machine
intelligence for some sort of decisions
practice execute because because
machines shouldn't have this dis bias by
default like they are not they shouldn't
bring this racial bias for example so
you're right in theory we can write
programs to be less biased in humans
usually you know as I was talking to
Peter Novick last week his head of
research at Google and he was saying you
know humans a terrible decision makers
we are we're full of all implicit biases
and we can't explain our decision-making
so there's no reason that I mean the
problem there are a number of challenges
though we don't we don't know how to
build algorithms that can explain
themselves we do know their black box we
know the machine learning evidence we
have at the moment pretty much black
boxes so they can't explain that
decision-making they can't provide they
can't explain why they came up with
particular decisions so that's what's
one of the challenges the second is that
we have on work as a society what these
biases what we mean to be fair yet we're
only starting to think about these
questions right so we can you say with
what we can eliminate the racial bias in
in policing right and sentencing well we
don't know what that really means I mean
you can say well we look at if we look
at the data we can say that you know
people in black people commit more crime
which might be true they might commit
more crime because they're poor crime is
often just a reflection of poverty right
or they might they may commit more crime
because they don't have access to to
mental health facilities crime is also
largely a function of you know as people
go to prisons there there are
substitutes of mental health hospitals
so we might be you know just reflecting
the fact that these people don't get
access to mental health care if we agree
the but we have integrated society
exactly but if we agree that the race
shouldn't be a factor for the machine
learning algorithm we could easily
remove that factor from the decision I
make it absolutely uniform across race
across X across well know the challenge
challenges agree intelligence if it's
just one which is just one dimension
that is easy insure we could say okay
we've got one one one one parameter sex
or you know you know income and we can
remove bias with one parameter but then
when you say well cable we've got
multiple amateurs we've got we've got
we've got that we want to remove bias
against we want to remove bias against
sex and gender at the same time now it
becomes much more challenging to define
what what does that mean
we don't know we haven't really worked
out yet what that means and we haven't
worked out society what that means so we
have to have a conversation as the first
technical question of you know if we've
got multiple dimensions that we try to
remove bias and hospitals but at the
same time is that actually possible and
it will probably I suspect will actually
discover there are some fundamental
impossibility we try to remove bias in
one dimension it may bias the other
dimension and so we may have to trade
off one against the other and then
secondly is we haven't worked out as a
society what it what we really want when
there's you know multiple parameters in
play what we're beginning to have those
conversation when we have those
conversations but so far we've been sold
this idea Google's a phobic Society Oh
I'm biased search results from whites
they're not they're paying a billion
dollar fine for the consequence of that
at the moment you know algorithms can be
a just as biased as humans depends on
the input it depends on the training
data it depends on many things that may
be implicit or explicit in how their
designs and how they're implemented yeah
but so far we've been trusting
algorithms blindly without thinking more
wait a second maybe there are some
biases that actually reflect poverty or
mental health access to mental health
that we don't want to happen we want to
Pecha wait because we just train off the
data that has that bias in it but so
these are both technical questions and
societal questions and I think you know
as a society we have to start having
these questions what do we want what
does it mean for it to be unbiased we've
only just beginning to have those sorts
of conversations but already there are
algorithms making decisions about
sentencing which seems to be you know
the horse is behind the cart there hi I
have a small follow-up question to the
one of our autonomous driving and I
guess when you hear the Tesla story the
first thing you think about is like why
aren't we working on a combination of
like computer and human and like having
them work together rather than try and
replace one or the other or although I
guess maybe in some ways that's quite
naive because we are training these
models using humans like in the
beginning to make some good decisions
well this could be huge benefits when we
have fully autonomous cars yeah I'd say
young people who can't drive to you
elderly people who can't drive
handicapped people who can't drive you
know and so people who can't drive for
me I hate driving driving is waste of
time I could be doing things I could be
working I could be relaxing you know so
it will be great benefits for all of us
when we don't have to drive and the
machine does all the driving focus right
now sorry we haven't achieved that and I
think yes I reckon
that's why is that not like the first
thing to make driving as safe as
possible with this combination of like
have some economies that also have the
human involved to the point where
they're still able to make some of those
decisions so that you're getting the
best of both worlds until you make it
the computer yeah yeah so you could you
could design most of technology so it's
just assisting it just socially like no
don't do that you can have an accident
right just be sitting there monitoring
that would make cars much safer but
would mean you wouldn't get some of the
other benefits of autonomy which which
are you get the time back you would just
get the safety benefits and I mean are
interesting enough you know if you want
a lot of what's today's I want to do is
just drive enough miles so it learns how
to drive right now interesting enough
they don't have to drive autonomously to
do that in fact there's an argument
they'll learn quicker if they don't
drive autonomously so if you're driving
autonomously you drive down the road and
you make a mistake well most the time
you make a mistake I mean when you as
Hugh may expect you mean you get lucky
you don't I you know all of us make lots
of mistakes driving and you know the
other person swerves or you know someone
wasn't coming down the road the wrong
way and you survive and you don't know
that you got lucky so in terms of
machine learning you don't get any
feedback you could driving down the road
and you make mistakes and you don't get
any from you know you only sleep eight
engages catastrophic like okay now we
made a mistake but the crash the car I
love them that and other people avoided
you you it's very hard for you to see
that you did the wrong thing and yet
somehow nothing happened so but if you
if you drive if you just sit there
monitoring the car as a computer
watching what the human does and you say
okay I want to turn left here the human
doesn't la Fidele
okay that was a mistake I can't turn
left there so the human gives you input
all the time which corrects what you
would have done and you see who's
against and see back from so you can
actually learn to drive much quicker by
observing a human than you can by
driving yourself because you get much
more direct immediate feedback than if
you than if you are just sitting there
not crashes and they only occasionally
getting some feedback from from the
works on the planet you get feedback all
the times of the driver as to what the
driver thought was a good thing to be
doing at that point if that's not what
you're doing then you could learn that
instantly so there's an argument that
actually Tesla could learn quicker if
they did you try dragged autonomously
but if they do now which is to provide
autonomous driving it's more sexy for
them to go it is it is it's good
addition okay we all agree that there
are a lot of questions we need to answer
especially with autonomous car like
these ethical questions who do we care
if we have to choose someone and such
questions do you believe that we
actually have the framework to work on
these questions are there like three
people working on it because from the
public side like for example in the
during the flash connection it doesn't
didn't really seem to be central to the
public debate right now even if for for
me which is writing it it feels really
real and actual well and if it if we
have this frame of view believe that we
do what we have to do to make the public
aware of it because for when you talk to
like random people who aren't
reconnected to the industry they really
have not any idea what's happening in
this also also as I mentioned before I
think we have really good historical
precedent here which is a liaison and so
I think the aviation industry gives us a
good model to try and follow so I think
there's a good idea of how you should
probably go about doing it as to the
public awareness yes you broke the
public is not aware which is right why
give talks like this which I wrote my
book try and stimulate the debate which
is not a debate that technologists need
to have what the public needs to have
but I think people are starting to wake
up to the idea and I mean you said in
the French election it wasn't the case
but in the last British election one of
the parties the Green Party now the
Green Party is not so big
you caressed his here in Germany or I
then how big it is in France but it's
still a small party but as part of their
manifesto they had transitioning to ubi
the universal basic income as part of
their political manifesto
that's pretty mainstream right and it
actually is in the manifesto of one of
the parties though maybe they got five
seven percent of the vote or something
but you know I was pretty surprised and
pretty pleased to see that it was in
mainstream politics the idea that it was
enough changed going a bottom about that
you should put in your manifesto
transitioning to universal basic income
as one of your pledges obviously this
Green Party never had a chance of
winning the election but the fact that
if it was there then listening that
people will accept okay well this is
universal basic income why why would we
want to worry about universal basic
income says to me that people I think a
starting to think about these issues and
we really do think about these issues
because most of the major car
manufacturers are talking about selling
autonomous cars in the next five or ten
years and you know forward have said
2021 they want to be something under for
the autonomous car and so they're going
to be you know driving around and within
a decade and the fact you can you can
buy something that drives autonomously
down the highway today already they're
going to be you know changing our lives
changing changing many aspects of our
society very soon unlike the Industrial
Revolution this this is going to happen
probably quicker and then just
revolution you had to build a big
expensive steam engines and bits of
machinery that took time and money and
capital this time you just need to copy
bits of code that takes no time it takes
no money it takes no capital maybe it's
almost free to copy code and and then
the other thing that people forget is
how quickly machines can learn compared
to humans something I didn't talk about
which is that that we're used to
learning things all ourselves right see
if you learn to ride a bicycle it
doesn't help that I've learned to ride a
bicycle right I can say to you well get
on the bicycle and pedal and
of handlebars but you can have to learn
it pretty much from scratch yourself
right whereas computers well if I've
written the code that learned to ride a
bicycle over here I just have to copy
the code over there it takes no time at
all to share that learning on another
computer and so you can learn on a
planet-wide scale every night Tesla
updates its software by learning from
every other Tesla we're used to learning
everything ourselves and it's slow and
painful
it doesn't learn we don't learn
planet-wide if we could learn
planet-wide
we'd all speak every language on the
planet we'd all play musical instruments
as well as anyone else on the planet all
our skills would be ratcheting up as
well as everyone else it will this is
why we're going to be surprised how
quickly it happens because as soon as
one computer learn something we can
share with every computer and we only
have to learn it once it's never
forgotten so it's going to surprise us
computers learn can learn so much better
so much quicker than we can learn and
that's something that we're not used to
it's not human-like scale it's it's good
for the completely alien to us ok hi
thanks for the talk
multiple times during your talk mg and
QA talked about the black box but as
machine learning in a lot of cases and I
remember in your talk you said we don't
understand what's going on there yet so
I've got two questions the first is how
likely do you think we're going to get
to a point where we stand say ok we
understand what's going on in a deep
learning algorithm and the second
question is if we don't get to that
point where we understand it do you see
it as a problem
this is a wonderful question and we
don't know don't see don't know I mean
we we might build intelligence we might
make big make these machines and they
behave intelligence they do all the
right things and we have no insight as
to how they work
and there's a good a good precedent for
this which is ourselves we have no idea
how our human brain works and maybe
we'll never work out the magic of our
human brain maybe we're not smart enough
to know how smart our brains are right
and so we may end up building
intelligence so this would be this would
be like the worst one a more depressing
outcome Treyarch we may end up building
intelligence and it will be just as
blackbox as our human brains are at
which you know I have to take what you
say on trust as you know Wells you know
you look like me you're behaving smartly
you're doing all the right things that
presumably what you're doing is okay and
so maybe we end up learning intelligence
like that and maybe maybe we will get in
size it's a completely open question we
don't know interesting so if you go to
Singapore the filing of autonomous taxes
in Singapore the company that's doing
that is doing it in a different way to
Google and uber which is doing it with
machine learning they've got a different
architecture so at the bottom level the
perception level perceiving the
environment working out what's going on
in the world is machine learning but the
top level that the control architecture
of their car is fuzzy logic the set of
rules it's not it's fuzzy because
because actually road traffic rules are
not precise right you are allowed to
cross over the white line to overtake to
avoid accidents you are allowed to the
speed to overtake you know you you are
allowed to go through yellow lights it's
just going to cause an angstrom you know
so that they're not people quickly
discovered that the road traffic rules
are not exact rules that there is some
interpretation so they've written the
rules in fuzzy logic so that they can
inspect them and if the car has an
accidental or does something it doesn't
isn't supposed to do they can say well
where's the rule for that and if there
isn't the rule for that they write
another or and so so that they can have
guarantees and so there is some more
transparency the top-level architecture
is one that they actually hand code with
rules
and so maybe we'll end up building
systems more like that where to
guarantee the behaviors we actually
write down explicit rules and then we
can be sure that is following those
rules and maybe relieved the machine
learning just for that sort of things
like the section where machine learning
is really super Beth Thanks behind you
now hi yeah
every much liked the point that you
brought about companies like so big like
Apple Google and so on that they have
interest that they are not aligned with
society so basically that they are not
paying the taxes and and so on so and
then you have these companies building
this AI and this kind of thing so how
good don't you have the feeling that
it's a bit of an educational problem
that these companies want to the
education problem so that people who are
leaving these companies don't wanna talk
with the rest of the society and their I
don't know only interested in their own
I don't know let's say benefit so how
could we align the interests of society
and the interests of those companies so
that they pay taxes so that they build
AI in the direction that we want to that
we want to have it you have any ideas
how could we yeah again it's a fantastic
question it's more than just an
education problem right these these
people went to good universities had
liberal education right but it's not
clear to me anymore that the corporate
structure which is there to maximize
supposedly to maximize shareholder value
is that is not even clear as maximizing
share value seems to be maximizing CEO
CEO pay really more more than anything
else at the moment but it gains
maximizing shareholder value whether
that aligns anymore with with society we
give that you've got to remember
corporations are artificial constructs
that we make as society there's no
necessity that they exist in the form
they do we invented this legally this
legal structure they are allowed to
commit manslaughter because leave this
corporate manslaughter now there are
legal entity like humans that act in our
plan on our world with certain rights
and responsibilities
they get immense freedoms to act right
they have limited liability which is an
immense freedom you know they have much
less liability than you and me
you know they if they lose all their
money they can't you know you know they
can walk away from everything where
there are certain debts that you and I
can't walk away from so that gives them
the great ability to act to generate
wealth and to do things and with that
freedom should come responsibility and
they there are some responsibilities but
it's not clear to me that we're
necessarily demanding enough
responsibility out of companies anymore
and that you know they play these games
about paying tax in low tax states or in
Noatak States which you know do not
align line with us you know fact that
they are acting in our society
benefiting from the education system the
road system and health care system all
the things that allow them to act and to
charge money for their products or
brought painful by the state and by
other people and you know therefore they
do have a responsibility to ensure that
carries on and I'm not an economist I'm
not a lawyer at the end of the day but
it seems to me you know you can
certainly look at me say well look look
at what happens in Scandinavia where
they have you know where they have
boards of companies which are more
representative of workers you know there
are other structures you can have and
there are other ways of forming
corporations we used to have more
cooperatives which were more aligned to
the benefits of the workers and you know
this seems to be there are lots of ideas
that we could we could try and borrow
and maybe ultimately I think we have to
reconsider the idea of corporation and
that it gets freedom to act but maybe it
has to be realigned if it works pretty
well for the industrial ushion but now
in this globalized world where taxes get
seem to get paid nowhere
maybe we have to come back and
reconsider how corporations should be
allowed to act so this global Texas I'm
not sure well you know what we're
prepared to accept but but but but you
know there are other solutions you know
many more more purchase taxes
there are lots of things there you know
these are big questions I mean I'm a
technologist I'm not a I'm not economist
and lawyer taxations Facebook but it
seems to me that it's not just technical
problems that these are very fundamental
issues do it's worth pointing out look
well when the Industrial Revolution
changed and corporations really started
we didn't really have you know
corporations only really started to get
whole when we had an industrial society
there are very few corporations that
existed pre the Industrial Revolution
there are a few Italian banks and a few
publishing houses but there was not much
that predates the Dutch revolution terms
of corporations the corporation is very
much a product of the Industrial
Revolution but we but we changed society
in fundamental ways and the just
revolutions happened we introduced
unions we need to use labor laws child
labor laws we introduced bank holidays
we introduced lots of things to protect
the rights of workers to make sure that
Karl Marx was wrong but it wasn't just
the owners of production that benefited
but all of us shared their prosperity
and I seems to mean we're perhaps going
through a similar change where only the
very wealthy the owners the robots will
prosper only the big tech companies will
prosper unless we more forcibly reduce
the wealth and make sure that all of us
share the prosperity and that's actually
necessary if we if our economies have to
go because because rich corporations
don't you know trickles their wealth now
words
you
[Applause]